i'm laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle from a still
rocking washington tonight now we're
going to get right into it
a tale of two futures
that's the focus of tonight's angle
you just witnessed two weeks two parties
conventions
and two visions for america now all week
long
america saw a republican party that was
hopeful and optimistic about the future
capped off by a soaring address from the
president last night
together we will write the next chapter
of the great american story
over the next four years we will make
america into the manufacturing
superpower of the world
the united states will be the first
nation to plant
its beautiful flag on mars we will
rekindle new faith in our values
new pride in our history and a new
spirit of unity that can only be
realized through love
for our great country
then much to the dismay of the media
home monitors
our energizer bunny president traveled
to new hampshire tonight
with thousands lined up to see and hear
him now once again
the contrast between him and biden
is stark this is going to be we are
right now in the most
important election in our history
last night it was my great honor to
accept
the republican nomination for president
of the united states
[Applause]
we're going to win i believe i have the
honor
of running against the worst candidate
ever put up by the democratic party
how do you get worse i believe he's the
worst candidate
the slowest candidate and i mean in
prime time he was the slowest candidate
which was a long time ago prime time
in trump's america we believe the best
is truly yet to come and this was said
over and over by speakers at the rnc
it wasn't just rhetoric though they
really mean it
and that buoyant sunny outlook wasn't
from celebrities who live behind walls
and gates and have handlers but from
every everyday americans who have always
been the focus of trump's agenda
for america president trump's economic
boon began helping dairy farmers across
the nation
when he sees something isn't right he's
fearless in fixing it
he listens to working people i was once
told that the only way
i would ever be reunited with my family
would be as a corpse but by the grace of
god
and the compassion of president donald
john trump
i stand before you tonight and i assure
you
i'm not a ghost and contrary to what the
long
faces in the press claim did you see
their faces last night
the president didn't run away from covid
he ran toward the issue
he noted the great tragedy we've
suffered talked about his own friends
who've passed away because of the
disease and the great strides we've
already made
now again the message we're pushing
forward with medical innovation
we've mobilized our now on the other
hand at their convention
the democrats painted a very depressing
gloomy portrait of american life
did you know that you live in a horrible
rotten awful country we call out and
confront the original sins of this
nation
the sins of slavery and racism it is the
effect
of structural racism let's be clear
there is no vaccine for racism
history has thrust one more urgent task
on us
will we be the generation that finally
wipes out the stain of racism
from our national character now while
the democrats were trying to convince
you that
poor old joe should be put in charge
they refused to address the elephant or
i should say the rabid donkey in the
room
the violence playing out in blue cities
across america didn't want to talk about
that during their convention
so the portland riots destruction in
seattle shooting and looting in chicago
did they think or maybe did they hope
that swing state voters and independents
somehow wouldn't see the video all over
social media
of all the burning and all the mayhem
now
as i told you back in june the democrats
had made a calculated decision
not to address the violence not to
address the violence and riots
as long as they thought that they were
going to be helping them politically
and sure enough the moment don lemon let
it slip
that some focus group somewhere was
showing democrat voter erosion because
of the unrest
well joe and kamala tried to turn the
titanic around
we must always defend peaceful protest
and peaceful protesters we should not
confuse them
with those looting and committing acts
of violence burning down communities
is not protest it's needless violence
violence that endangers lives violence
that guts businesses and shutters
businesses
serve the community that's wrong talk
about
desperate and delusional now it's too
bad he and kamala
didn't have an entire convention week to
contem condemn the riots right
oh wait of course they did now trump has
offered assistance to
every governor and every mayor grappling
with out-of-control violence
and how did they respond first i want to
assure the president that seattle is
fine
we have dozens if not hundreds of
federal troops descending upon our city
it's not helping the situation at all
they're not wanted here
mr president bring those kind of uh
troops
to our city and try to take off and
that's not gonna happen in chicago we're
gonna fight with everything
that we have um donald trump and his
minions are the architects of chaos in
this country
right now wait a second wait a second
it's trump
with the architects okay they wanted the
violence to go on
joe biden claimed now by that logic
did he enjoy these scenes last night
after the festivities ended how
do you feel about police
killing black people
now i actually don't believe that poor
old joe likes these scenes
doesn't want it all burned down and
people hassled in the streets but he's
too weak to stop it and by the same
token
i think there are a lot of democrats who
are probably embarrassed about the
party's
unsavory alliances their devil's bargain
with their donor class on outsourcing
american jobs
placating china and do i think most
moderate democrats want our cities to
just
be flattened mount rushmore to come down
no i actually don't but it doesn't
matter they chose joe biden one of the
weakest candidates in modern history
as their nominee and as victor davis
hanson said last night
biden has become a prisoner of his own
paradox
because he himself has no energy he
tried to ride the energy of the far left
all the way to victory on november third
but now it looks like that wave
has pulled him under and a riptide of
radicalism
is drowning the democrats they have
nothing to offer the voters
they can't solve the violence problem
and they're not equipped to fix it
i ask you a simple question how can the
democrat party
ask to lead our country when it spends
so much time tearing down our country
they can't bring back jobs when their
trade policies lead to
more outsourcing for 47 years joe biden
took the donations of blue-collar
workers and then he flew back to
washington
and voted to ship our jobs to china
china supports
joe biden and desperately wants him to
win i can tell you that
upon very good information and the idea
that joe biden's going to solve covet oh
please
he said he's going to lock us down if
the experts say so into years of
economic decline of course
and we know it'll lead to increased
suicide addiction
job losses and democrats solution
is to hurt kids by keeping them out of
school during covet
and take away our simple joys like
playing or watching football
none of that will solve covet but it
will make our lives miserable
and so all democrats have left is two
arguments number one
america is systemically racist and
number two
trump is bad the rnc blew up that
narrative though in a big way
showcasing stories from everyday
americans whose lives were
impacted in profoundly positive ways by
trump's america first policies
including african-american men and women
now this outreach has the democrat
ticket i think it has it completely
flummoxed
as we saw in this today show interview
of kamala harris
compared to rnc's past
there seems to be a larger number of
black men
front and center it would seem as if
republicans
perhaps see an opportunity here the
democrats don't see
first of all every vote needs to be
earned
and joe and i believe that so when we
look at the condition of black men in
america we know we still have a whole
lot of work to do
wait a second your party has had decades
to solve these problems as you falsely
peddled that
narrative that republicans are racist
and now trump
was delivering results and the democrats
only
know one thing reverting back to the
same
stale old narratives the democrats are
the ones trapped in the past now and
and spending time with them it feels
kind of like you're
you're stuck in a student sit-in that
never ends
look at what their voters are doing to
people just trying to live their lives
what's a mask on now huh
[Music]
but it doesn't have to be this way there
is a normal world out there and
people in red states are already back to
living in that world
school work sports church
fellowship i'm really excited about
america in 2021 and 2022.
i think the silent majority is stirring
don't you
without kovid trump would have won in a
landslide but even with the virus
remember this it's eventually going to
go away or we'll have better
therapeutics or treatments
but it's no reason to toss america in a
dumpster
and set her on fire that's what the
democrats are doing to their own cities
they're now at risk of being left behind
for decades
if they don't make serious changes now
but that's up to them
but they're not going to stop us from
living our god-given destiny
and reaching for the stars they might
have given up on america
but the rest of us are giving her our
all
and that's the angle